bonjour merci d'être en direct sur rt
france alors pas de chiffres exacts sur
le montant de la fraude est ce que ça
montre pas qu'il ya des lacunes que ce
n'est pas vraiment clair oui tout à fait
bonjour a tous déjà il faut savoir que
la fraude sociale est évalué dans le
précédent rapport à 20 milliards d'euros
en france sachant que trois quarts
venait du travail dissimulé viendrait du
travail dissimulé et un quart viendrait
d'une fraude aux prestations sociales
c'est vrai que les budgets sont
considérables a beaucoup plus importants
que l'état on a 600 milliards de
prestations sociales diverses dont les
plus importantes de loin sont les
retraites et l'assurance maladie pour
500 milliards d'euros et il y aurait un
taux de fraude donc de 3%
mais ce qui est très important au delà
de ce rapport de la cour des comptes que
j'ai regardé mais qui n'est pas très
précis c'est le travail de charles prat
et de la sénatrice nathalie goulet
auquel il faut rendre hommage parce que
sont les traits de fer de lance pour
cette lutte contre la fraude sociale et
notamment cette fraude aux prestations
puisque en fait on se rend compte qu'on
a 74 millions de numéros de personnes
inscrits à la sécurité sociale et on à
2.4 millions au minimum deux dossiers
phantom voire beaucoup plus encore selon
le rapport la cour des comptes que ces
dossiers n'ont jamais été investiguées
et qu'il y a eu lui même ce qui est un
scandale absolu un refus de répondre des
organismes de sécurité sociale à une
sénatrice à une élue de la république
il ya une espèce de tolérance par des
organismes de sécurité sociale à cette
fraude et je remercie chars le prat de
travailler avec ardeur sur sept ce sujet
de levé ce lièvre
alors pas de chiffres mais une chose est
sûre et vous venez de le dire cette
fraude existe elle coûte à la france
alors la cour des comptes insiste sur le
fait que les contrôles ne sont pas
efficaces pourquoi ne le font-ils pas
pourquoi ne sont ils pas première chose
parce que il ya une forme de tolérance
henry j'en ai discuté avec un ami alors
que je nommerai pas mais qui est un
ancien patron d'un organisme de sécurité
sociale
il ya une forme de tolérance vis-à-vis
de 110 en place et des fraudeurs c'est
des petits c'est les petites gens des
gens pauvres donc c'est pas très grave
ce qui est d'autant plus
honteux que en fait on a 30 % on à
linverse 30% des gens qui devraient
avoir des prestations sociales comme des
rsa et qui ne le demande pas des petites
gens soient pas ronde soit parce
qu'elles ne connaissent pas en fait 7 7
la possibilité d'avoir des prestations
il y a aussi le fait que les fichiers
sont très mal tenu comment ça se fait
qu'on a 2e 4 millions de dossiers
fantôme apparemment actifs
comment ça se fait qu'on a des gens qui
a 120 ans des cartes vitale sur lequel
il touche delà des prestations
d'assurance maladie comme nous
l'expliquent charles pratin qui est un
magistrat spécialiste sur ce sujet voilà
donc la fraude sociale
il faut le rappeler est un vol c'est un
vol de l'argent qui est destiné aux
retraités aux maladies et ça devrait
être légitimé des prisons de la prison
et des amendes comme tout vol
donc il faudrait selon vous réformer à
tout système alors comment s'y prend
comme ans il prend ma déjà la première
chose c'est une erreur évidente qui a
été fait par les élites de notre pays
c'est de tout des matières égaliser
quand vous commencez vous vous inscrivez
la sécurité sociale ou prou à la route
voilà par exemple ou à une autre
prestation sociale
maintenant vous pouvez faire avec des
documents dans voyant par internet des
documents et des copies de documents
il est évident que c'est beaucoup moins
efficace que d'avoir une personne sur
place qui a obligé de se déplacer qui va
montrer ses différents papiers
d'identité ses différents documents sur
lequel on pourra beaucoup plus
facilement repérer une fraude que des
envois par internet
et puis il faut aussi des détecteurs de
faux documents
donc il faut beaucoup de contrôle face à
face notamment des retraités à
l'étranger puisque vous imaginez bien
qu'il ya beaucoup de retraités à lettres
qui sont payés à l'étranger d'après le
document de la cour des comptes ya 7
millions cette retraitée pays à
l'étranger ce qui est complètement
incompréhensible qu'il ya 12 millions de
retraités français et donc on se
retrouve avec quelque chose de qui ne va
pas parce qu'il ya sept contrôleurs
aussi il n'y a pas de fichier de
personnes qui ont fait une fraude aux
prestations sociales et qui devrait être
visible pour l'ensemble des autres
organismes de prestations sociales afin
de recouper et d'éviter et de contrôle
et particulièrement les fraudeurs et
puis il faut aussi une loi qui met des
sanctions pénales forte et des amendes
pénales très forte
les dernières choses il faut que le
gouvernement elise des directeurs
d'organismes de sécurité sociale qui
soit sérieux parce que ces gens gèrent
600 milliards d'euros et la fraude c'est
du vol
philippe un murray remercie d'avoir été
en direct avec nous sur rt france je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste merci